vestido con un uniforme blanco y negro
hadi matar de 24 años permaneció en
silencio en su comparecencia ante el
tribunal el jueves nuevamente se declaró
no culpable hablando fuera del juzgado
el fiscal del distrito jason james hizo
una actualización sobre la situación del
caso
la forma en que el estatuto de crimen de
odio funciona en el estado de nueva york
es que aumenta sirve como un dispositivo
de intensificación para que ya sabes
digamos un delito de nivel ve ahora
pueda subir un escalón así que estamos
viviendo eso elegimos no acusarlo por
razones que es importante para nosotros
ir con los hechos y la ley y esa es
nuestra decisión por ahora
nadie fue atacado mientras estaba en el
escenario de un evento literario en el
estado de nueva york el pasado viernes
sufriendo graves heridas matar fue
detenido en el lugar de los hechos el
miércoles declaró al new york post que
no le gustaba rushdie que según él había
atacado al islam todo ello mientras
admitía que sólo había leído dos páginas
de su controvertida novela 'los versos
satánicos' también se mostró sorprendido
de autor hubiera sobrevivido al ataque
comentando la entrevista el fiscal se me
dijo que podría ser usada en el caso por
su parte el abogado deja de matar pidió
al juez impedir que los periodistas
traten de ponerse en contacto con su
cliente fuera de la sala increpó a una
multitud de ellos
de nuevo la orden del juez julio hoy fue
no hablar de ninguno de los detalles de
este caso no voy a hacerlo no voy a
discutirlo
ustedes escucharon mis argumentos en la
corte no voy a hacer ningún comentario
adicional en este momento
matar nació y creció en eeuu pero tiene
raíces familiares en el sur del líbano
su próxima comparecencia ante el
tribunal está prevista para septiembre